marie-amélie le fur marraine du congrès
national des pompiers comment pouvait-il
en être autrement
la double championne paralympique de rio
licencié à blois et aux tours et nantes
10 sport était cadette chez les pompiers
dans sa jeunesse
double championne de france pompiers son
mari est pompier son entraîneur et
pompiers après son accident en 2004 ce
sont les pompiers qui lui ont offert sa
première lame d'athlétisme les pompiers
c'est sa famille la famille des pompiers
fait partie de ma vie depuis début ils
ont été là au moment de l'accident dans
la reconstruction
pour fêter les titres donc fêté voilà
cette belle réussite de rio par le
congrès des sapeurs-pompiers national à
tours je pense que je pouvais pas rêver
mieux et pas rêver un meilleur partage
dans trois jours marie amélie aura 28
ans peut-être l'occasion pour elle de
souffler un peu
des bougies au moins pour le reste elle
compte bien mettre son énergie ses
performances son intelligence au service
du plus grand objectif du sport français
ce sera soutenir la candidature de paris
2024 pour obtenir les jeux en france ce
serait vraiment une belle chose en
termes d'héritage pour les structures
pour le handisport pour le sport
français
et puis après peut-être prendre les
crampons fin les les pointer et revenir
d'ici et tokyo l'athlète de naveil peut
en être certaine les pompiers seront
toujours derrière elle et marie amélie
toujours avec eux